No, this is happening right now.
An increasing number of Republicans are attacking no fault divorce.
They wanna make it harder to get a divorce,
70% of which are initiated by women.
The Texas and Nebraska
Republican parties put it in their state's official platform.
And what I'm guessing you're trying to say is, yeah,
but Republicans will never actually make it harder to get a divorce.
Like, these bills would never pass.
This is never going to happen.
It is justified and warranted
and even necessary
that we react to the things that legislators say that they want to do.
Like, what's the alternative?
We only get to react when the deed is done,
when they do actually make it harder to get a divorce.
This type of thoughtless,
dismissive tactic was used so much
when women and feminists and activists
sounded the alarms for years and decades
that Republicans would overturn Roe v.
Wade,
only to be told time and time again that they won't actually do it.
I certainly hope you're right.
I hope this never happens.
But I plan to continue reacting to Republicans
when they tell me what they wanna do.